I knew I was gonna win some money on the
Super Bowl just how much yeah I thought
I was gonna win everything I thought I'd
bet a lot more yeah thank goodness I
didn't I seem to I have seen someone
much my money from you which I got here
20 40 60 80 100 20 40 60 80 100 20 40 50
you know someone else must owe me money
yeah I wasn't the only one who lost to
you who else owes me money
how would I have the tape of Jackie and
Robin betting yeah and it sort of it
sort of wait I mean I guess it's a bet
you know things were going sort of fast
but Jackie says I got a hundred bucks as
a Green Bay Oh score first Robert says I
say no and let's go first and then
nobody knows anything they didn't take I
mean I'll play it for you and you can
decide sounds like it's a push Robert
just said nobody ever said okay we're
sat on that then Robert said oh I say
New England scores first I bet a couple
of people I gave him 14 points yeah I
know he had a 40 no it's a push but
there were lots of bets and we have to
say like I definitely bet like Jackie
just threw it out there you know what it
is you're type B and type B people
sluggish are sluggish and don't care
like I would have been if I if I was the
guy in charge I would win so
anal-retentive okay stop
you bet what you type B and you know
what a Type A does he goes back and
listen to the tape and checks his work
yeah no we went over all the bets even
on the a we're all say goes because you
missed them you missed bet you can
listen to this bad type a goes back or a
type 8 says one of the interns go back
and check home I don't think I'm a Type
A and I don't care because you're a Type
A hole no you're not
you're not a type at you're an a and
it's not a put-down it's your time but
they're not a type a you're not one of
those people who's meticulous why don't
you say why don't you say right you're
not meticulous you're sloppy I see you
getting insulted do genetics give you
you're a Type A or type B yeah and B
isn't necessarily bad you're gonna live
a lot longer wife or being a jerk it's
up between you and Robin try getting
your hundred bucks out of her go good
then don't worry about it a type-a lives
less or or will die sooner because they
worry about everything their compulsive
their people who that's why they're
mostly successful Taipei's type page
with your high-powered successful people
yeah people who stroke out or have a
heart attack at 50 a type B is like a
Gary who will always live under the wing
of a Type A he lived to be a hundred
right and he will live a long time he
will be the guy who rises right but the
book will be real bad cuz he's a type me
just like he wouldn't have taken
meticulous notes he'll just have like
you know he'll just have to rely on it
stories about the great person he worked
with will be very vague and the book
about you will be very detailed typey
typey will live a lot longer you'll say
Gary will live outlive everyone because
he just like to him it's like yeah I'll
take some bets and in fact whatever I
get I get whenever I don't I'd known
it's no big deal you know a Type A from
a Type B type a was sitting next to Type
B on the plane type a was working type B
was sleeping right he had his mouth open
and drool coming out what were you doing
on that plane trip I was doing a lot of
work you couldn't sleep that was your
work my mind is very active when burning
up a lot of because they plotting and
planning the next moves for us while you
rest
Robin your type wat I'm a Type C what's
that mean
got that right see you next Tuesday
[Laughter]